Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour, je m’appelle Hervé Le Bras.
Je suis démographe et historien à l’École
des Hautes Études en Sciences Sociales.
Ce dont je vais vous parler
porte un titre :
« Le Grand remplacement,
est-ce sérieux ? » -
point d’interrogation -
« Comment bâtir une réponse ? »
Chaque mot, vous le verrez, a un sens.
Comment d’abord étudier
cette question du Grand remplacement
qui a beaucoup occupé la presse
et la politique ces derniers temps,
et pas simplement en France.
61% des Français
dans un sondage de Challenges
disent qu’ils craignaient
ce grand remplacement.
Pour l’étudier, je vais faire appel
à des sciences sociales
parce qu’elles permettent, si l’on peut
dire, de conjurer deux difficultés :
une difficulté créée
par la question de l’objectivité
et une autre créée
par les pièges du langage.
Par les sciences sociales, au fond.
Première question : quelles sciences
sociales ? Il y en a beaucoup.
On ne peut pas être omniscient,
il faut partir de l’une d’entre elles.
L’une d’entre elles, pour moi, ce sera
la démographie avec des statistiques,
mais je ne vous ensevelirai pas
sous les nombres.
Autour, j’utiliserais des sciences
sur lesquelles j’ai
un peu de compétences :
de la linguistique, de la sociologie,
de l’anthropologie notamment.
Les deux difficultés, je vais
d’abord en parler un peu plus
avant de les mettre en situation dans
cette question du Grand remplacement.
Première difficulté : l’objectivité.
Si vous êtes astronome,
si vous êtes mathématicien,
cela ne pose pas de gros problèmes.
Mais quand vous faites
des sciences sociales,
vous êtes une partie de l’observation,
vous faites partie de la société.
Donc vous ne pouvez pas
complètement vous libérer,
complètement être au-dessus de la société
sur laquelle vous voulez
porter des jugements
ou comprendre des fonctionnements.
On appelle ce problème-là celui
de la neutralité axiologique.
Donc il faut chercher à s'en rapprocher.
On s’en rapproche d’une certaine manière,
à la fois en étudiant des faits
et en contrôlant des opinions.
Quand je dis des faits,
cela veut dire qu’il faut les préciser,
il faut en donner
exactement la construction.
Les opinions, il faut savoir
comment elles sont recueillies,
comment elles sont enquêtées.
Ça, c’est la partie objectivité.
Maintenant, les pièges du langage.
La nature, la réalité,
elle n’a pas de nom, elle est innommée.
Donc il faut lui plaquer des mots
pour en décrire,
ou estimer en décrire certains aspects.
Il faut forger des mots,
dit la philosophe Judith Butler.
Ces mots-là sont des mots souvent...
pas ambigus, mais avec plusieurs sens,
polysémiques.
Voilà encore un autre mot un peu savant,
mais l’idée de plusieurs sens
est assez évidente.
Par exemple, si j’emploie le mot « jeu ».
Le mot « jeu », J - E - U,
peut représenter à la fois
des jeux comme le jeu d’échecs,
ou bien le football est un jeu,
mais aussi « parier ».
Vous avez entendu parler
de la Française des Jeux, par exemple.
Donc c’est un problème
qui est très difficile à régler.
On pourrait dire :
« Mais il suffit de bien définir le jeu. »
Mais vous le définiriez avec d’autres mots
et à ce moment-là, il faudrait définir ces
autres mots dans une régression sans fin.
Donc finalement,
on passe directement au discours
une fois qu’on pense avoir à peu près
clarifié les mots qu’on emploie.
Mais ça crée une distance assez forte
entre la réalité et le discours.
Certains parlent de construction
sociale de la réalité en disant :
« C’est vraiment un écart
très très important. »
Mais on peut quand même le réduire
en travaillant les mots que l’on utilise,
notamment en faisant par exemple
leur histoire, leur étymologie,
mais surtout leur emploi.
Un grand philosophe, Ludwig Wittgenstein,
confronté à ce problème des mots,
a une définition qui est un peu terrible.
Il a dit : « En fait, le sens d’un mot,
c’est l’ensemble de ses emplois
dans le langage. »
Vous n'êtes pas très avancé avec cela.
Il a aussi montré le danger
que représentent les mots
avec une sentence qu’on nous
répète souvent, qui est :
« La philosophie bataille contre
l’ensorcellement de notre intelligence
par le langage. »
C’est la philosophie,
mais ce sont aussi les sciences sociales.
Voilà les difficultés auxquelles
nous devons faire face
si on veut aborder le problème
dont je vous ai parlé.
Alors ce problème ?
Ce problème,
c’est celui du « Grand Remplacement ».
J’ai écrit un petit ouvrage
à ce sujet-là l’année dernière.
Vous voyez qu’il est catégorique,
mais on ne va pas se limiter au titre.
On va chercher à voir pourquoi j’émets
un jugement aussi catégorique
en reprenant les deux difficultés.
Je commencerais par la première,
qui est la question linguistique :
qu’est-ce que signifie
« Grand remplacement » ?
Pour éclairer cette recherche
de signification de grand remplacement,
je m’inspirerais d’un travail d’un autre
philosophe, Jean-Pierre Faye,
sur le langage totalitaire.
Il s’est demandé comment
l’expression « national-socialisme »
était apparue
dans l’Allemagne des années 30.
Il a montré qu’il y avait une suite
de rapprochements qui s’étaient produits,
à la fois politiques et littéraires,
qui ont amené à la fusion de ces deux
termes, national et socialisme.
De la même manière,
« grand remplacement »,
c’est la fusion de deux termes :
« grand » et « remplacement ».
« Grand », on le trouve déjà
dans un roman à coloration raciste
de l’écrivain Jean Raspail,
« Le Camp des Saints »,
où on voit un million d’Indiens faméliques
débarquer sur une plage à côté
de Saint-Tropez et envahir la France.
Souvent dans le livre,
Jean Raspail dit « grande migration »,
donc « grand » y est.
Remplacement ?
Remplacement, c’est plus tard.
C’est une étude des Nations Unies -
très belle étude -
qui s’appelle « Population Replacement ».
C'est une étude théorique.
Les Nations Unies se sont demandé
quelle est l’importance des migrations
qu’il faudrait engendrer
pour que la population ne diminue pas
ou bien pour qu’il n’y ait pas
vieillissement de la population.
Donc ce sont des calculs abstraits.
Mais ces calculs ont été pris au sérieux
et ont donné un grand retentissement
au mot « remplacement »,
si bien qu’un peu plus tard,
un littérateur, Renaud Camus,
les a accolés et a écrit un livre qui
porte le titre « Grand remplacement »,
qui a inspiré la suite.
Qui l’a inspiré au point
que le terme a été repris,
comme vous le savez,
par différents partis
à l’extrémité droite du spectre politique.
Que ce soit Marine Le Pen
qui a plusieurs fois cité,
d’ailleurs à tort et à travers,
l’étude des Nations Unies,
ou bien [Philippe] de Villiers idem,
et surtout Eric Zemmour qui en a fait
le grand slogan de sa campagne.
Même au moment de la primaire
de la droite,
les cinq candidats ont dit
qu’ils craignaient ce grand remplacement.
Donc, apparemment, ça devrait être
considéré comme quelque chose de sérieux.
Mais quand on lit l’ouvrage
attentivement -
les ouvrages, ce que j’ai fait -
de Renaud Camus,
on voit que c’est modérément argumenté.
Par exemple, j’ai fait une chose -
Ce type de travail -
Quand on analyse une question,
ce qu’on peut faire,
c’est vérifier
les citations de Renaud Camus.
une grande partie d’entre elles
sont ou tronquées ou biaisées,
et même dans certains cas, sont inventées,
ce qui jette immédiatement un doute
sur la réalité de ce grand remplacement.
Maintenant, comment aborder
le second aspect des choses ?
Je vais vous dire un mot
dans un instant de ce petit graphique.
C’est la question des faits -
on a vu la question de la linguistique,
seconde difficulté, les faits.
Les faits -
Il faut d’abord savoir au fond -
je devrais avoir commencé par là -
ce que c’est que ce grand remplacement.
Renaud Camus dit : « C’est une évidence, »
ça ne nous avance pas beaucoup.
Quand on le lit, on voit
qu’il est obligé de dire ce que c’est.
Il dit : « C’est un peuple
remplace un autre peuple. »
« Un peuple », voilà un mot qui est
quand même un mot très abstrait,
très polysémique, justement.
Quels peuples ? Quel peuple remplaçant
et quel peuple remplacé ?
Le peuple remplacé,
on voit à peu près de quoi il s’agit.
Ce sont des Français qui sont, à plusieurs
générations près, d’origine française,
qui n’ont pas d’immigrés
dans une ascendance proche.
Le peuple des remplaçants, c’est plus
ambigu parce que qu’est-ce que c’est ?
Les Musulmans ? Mais combien sont-ils ?
Comment les compter ? C’est une religion.
Les Noirs, les Arabes, là aussi,
comment les compter ?
Est-ce que ça serait aussi -
Il faudrait y ajouter les Afghans, les
Chinois, les Vénézuéliens, pourquoi pas ?
Grosso modo, la seule manière de faire est
d’aller beaucoup plus large et de prendre
tous les immigrés et les descendants
d’immigrés sur deux générations.
On a là les deux et à ce moment-là,
on peut chercher
s’il y a vraiment remplacement.
Est-ce que les remplaçants vont devenir
plus nombreux que les remplacés ?
C’est ce que montre ce graphique.
Premier essai, regardons de combien la
population immigrée augmente chaque année.
On peut le savoir parce que l’INSEE fait
des enquêtes de recensement chaque année
sur 9 millions de personnes au hasard.
C’est du sérieux, ce n’est pas
l’enquête Ifop à 1000 personnes.
Ensuite, on fait des ventilations
et notamment une ventilation
du nombre d’immigrés selon leur origine.
Quand vous comparez
une année à la suivante,
vous pouvez voir combien
il y a d’immigrés en plus.
La réponse,
vous l’avez sur ce petit graphique,
la moyenne, c’est 122 000 personnes,
122 000 personnes de plus par an.
C’est à mettre en regard
avec la population française.
Si on prend même les Français sans
les étrangers, c'est 63 millions.
Cela veut dire que chaque année, vous
avez un 500e de la population française
qui augmente du fait des immigrés.
Autrement dit, beaucoup d’eau
aura coulé sous les ponts avant que
les populations comprenant
tous ces immigrés
remplacent la population française.
La seconde méthode,
c’est une méthode plus scientifique :
on fait une prévision
ou une projection de population.
Mais il faut distinguer
différentes catégories,
voir comment elles se marient entre elles,
comment elles forment des couples,
combien elles ont d’enfants,
comment elles meurent.
On a tous les chiffres.
On peut voir -
C’est pour donner
une idée de la complexité.
Ce sont les unions au niveau
de la seconde génération.
Un des conjoints peut être enfant d’union
mixte ou un enfant d’immigrés, etc.
Mais en fait,
on est allé plus loin avec l’INSEE.
C’est au niveau de la 3e génération,
au niveau des grands-parents.
Là, c’est assez compliqué,
mais on arrive à s’en tirer.
Le résultat, il est très net.
Le résultat, c’est que vous faites
année par année cette projection,
comme on fait
des projections de population.
Arrivé en 2050, vous avez la population
d’origine majoritairement immigrée,
c’est-à-dire ayant trois ou quatre
grands-parents immigrés,
ou deux parents immigrés,
ou étant immigrée elle-même,
c’est 20%.
La population d’origine mixte,
c’est aussi 20%.
Le reste, 60%, c’est une population
qui n’est pas d’origine immigrée,
au moins quand on remonte
sur deux générations.
À nouveau, même conclusion :
ce grand remplacement est un fantasme.
Vous voyez qu’on y a répondu en essayant
de contourner les deux difficultés
que j'avais signalées au début.
Mais le fait de faire ce genre
de recherches, d’études, de tests,
ça vous amène, comme toujours en
approfondissant, à de nouvelles questions.
La nouvelle question vient immédiatement :
« Mais pourquoi alors
croit-on au grand remplacement ? »
C'est une question plus difficile.
À la limite, il faudrait aller
du côté de la psychologie.
Il y a quand même deux éléments
que je vais résumer assez rapidement.
Le premier élément, c'est qu'on a très
souvent l'idée d'un cas particulier.
« C’est l’arbre qui cache la forêt. »
Notamment quand on parle
de cette question, on dit :
« Vous n’avez pas vu
ce qui se passe dans le 93. »
ou bien « le métro parisien », ou bien
« les quartiers nord de Marseille ».
Il y a cette idée qu’il y a
une extension assez rapide
de ces noyaux très importants
de l’immigration,
au lieu d’y voir en fait un problème
qui est un problème de ségrégation,
parce que ces noyaux
n’augmentent pas beaucoup.
Je vous ai mis une carte.
C’est une carte en anamorphose :
les surfaces sont proportionnelles
au nombre d’immigrés.
Vous voyez que ce sont essentiellement les
très grandes villes qui ont des immigrés.
Sur le reste, en bleu, vous avez très peu
d’immigrés, des proportions très faibles.
Des particularités :
en haut, vous voyez bien
la Seine-Saint-Denis,
puis vous voyez bien Paris
qui occupe une large place.
Ce sont des endroits
où il y a beaucoup d’immigrés.
Ce qui est particulièrement
intéressant, c’est, par exemple,
le bleu dans le Pas-de-Calais
ou bien dans l’Aisne.
Ce sont des endroits où beaucoup
ont peur du Grand remplacement.
Ils le prouvent en votant
pour des partis d’extrême-droite,
que ce soit Reconquête
ou bien Marine Le Pen.
Regardez les deux cartes
faites de façon normale.
Vous voyez qu’il n’y a pas de
correspondance entre ces deux cartes.
Et même, plus précisément, on peut dire -
et c’est la situation en France :
plus il y a de peur du grand remplacement,
plus il y a de votes
pour des partis extrémistes de droite.
Plus on est dans une zone rurale,
loin des grandes villes,
plus la commune où on habite est
petite, moins il y a d’immigrés.
Ce qui semble un paradoxe
tout à fait étrange.
Ce n’est pas simplement au niveau de la
France, on peut prendre la diapo suivante.
Je vous ai mis la région parisienne.
En haut, vous voyez la proportion
d’immigrés par commune d’Ile de France,
en bas, les votes pour Marine Le Pen
au premier tour de la présidentielle.
Vous regarderez dans le détail :
les deux cartes sont absolument
l’inverse l’une de l’autre.
Autrement dit :
moins il y a d’immigrés,
plus on vote pour la peur de l’immigré,
qui est le slogan le plus important
du Rassemblement national.
Ce n’est pas simplement en France.
En Allemagne, c’est la même chose.
D’un côté, j’ai mis la proportion
d’étrangers par Kreis
qui est l’équivalent
des arrondissements en France.
C’est très important
dans les zones qui marchent bien
économiquement en Allemagne.
L’AFD, qui est le parti d’extrême-droite
allemand, maintenant pratiquement nazi,
c’est presque uniquement
l’ancienne Allemagne de l’Est,
où vous n’avez absolument pas de migrants.
Comment expliquer ce paradoxe ?
C’est qu’au fond, quand vous n’avez pas de
migrants, vous en avez beaucoup plus peur.
Vous ne les connaissez pas.
Il n’y a pas la diversité
que vous avez avec les immigrés
Et du fait que vous en
avez plus peur, vous -
Le terme « immigrants »,
ou le terme « grand remplacement »,
qui au fond, l’a -
si on peut dire - remplacé,
devient une sorte de réceptacle,
une sorte d’aimant,
pour tous les problèmes
que vous rencontrez,
pour les ressentiments que vous avez,
et finit par leur donner un nom,
leur donner une forme.
Et je vais finir
par cette remarque d’ailleurs,
qui s’inscrit à côté de ce que
nous a dit au début [Wiitgenstein] :
« Formidable les mots,
mais aussi extrêmement dangereux. »
Vous voyez qu’ils ont cette capacité
de concentrer des contenus
qui ne leur correspondent pas
dans leur acception la plus simple.
C’est au fond un danger
qui a bien été décrit très tôt,
et une force politique, malheureusement,
qui a été décrite par un philosophe
et homme politique italien,
Antonio Gramsci,
quand il a parlé d’hégémonie culturelle.
Nous avons en permanence à lutter
contre des hégémonies culturelles,
à lutter contre les mots au fond
plus que contre les contenus.
(Applaudissements)